[Music]
mando on 420 okay so I got a
notification from IGN channel the
mandalorian season 2 trailer on Disney
plus I'm a little bit suspicious because
it's only on IGN why don't I have more
notifications about this clicked on the
video I haven't seen yet obviously
that's number 3 on trending so I'm like
okay um April
I like month Jo alright let's let's see
[Music]
you have something I want you may think
you have some idea what you're in
possession of but you do not it's pretty
cool
it is real
could just be cobbled together yeah me
go for a well may be suspicious because
I saw the I clicked on it there is so
many dislikes you know it's just a
really bad trailer from the show Oh God
Wow dami going for a Louise I'm like
whose sub getting chills getting excited
this is feeling real I'm not sure but is
this real this is really good it was
like when they did that Zelda April
Fool's trailer years ago where I was
like this looks pretty convincing odds
it's not it's cuz they're taking the
lines from Giancarlo Esposito and
they're overlapping it you're like okay
this could be a real lead-in teaser
trailer there were images rose like okay
I think I've seen this image before but
it's common for season two trailers or
sequel trailers to use footage from
before before we start seeing some new
clips no he's back in his ship I mean
we'll get similar angles anyway and then
we started hearing mando talk and I'm
like I've never heard the hell I'm
before oh this must be real footage now
certainly get suspicious with some of
the slowing down and the framerate
moments are like coming back and forward
is that really petrified Scala's voice
like I really had to hone in on it cuz
it was a pretty decent impression if it
wasn't actually him when you cut to him
and then you see smoke in the room was
like oh guys
and I love the punch of how baby Yoda
has grown how he looks different
showing Groot there made me think of
like the the teen group joke that when
you first see garbage seaman guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 so I felt like they
were kind of playing on that side I
don't think it would hurt it wouldn't
have been as funny if baby odor just a
like regular baby Yoda and just had some
joint in his hand with the fact that he
had it's like ridiculous the clothes
take joint yeah how strange he looks in
his hand I'm not picking up on what that
hand is from that looked like it could
either be like those creatures from
Ghostbusters or gremlins I it's not
coming to mind right right now for me
well that's the thing is Yoda in this
baby Yoda looked very janky almost like
you would see in like a full moon
features type of like if they did a Yoda
knockoff oddly perfect for a pot parody
because like that's always with it like
even if you think about like scary movie
when Ghost Face is smoking a joint like
it's the kind of janky looking at yeah
so really follows in that suit and
weirdly with all this going on in the
world I feel like April Fool's really
lost its shine nobody wanted to do that
yeah I feel like 4/20 is a better
version of that whereas like if we have
like four or five of these kind of in
yeah or it's just like here's a random
trailer that turns into a pot joke I
think that's actually kind of better and
I gotta say you know like the production
that they put together for it it was
actually not bad looking it was pretty
good I feel like you you owe it alike
just for that alone
yeah just for being convincing perhaps
okay what is the description box say
here did jar and has traveled far made
many enemies and shouldered the burden
of some very precious cargo but his
journey is far from over
men lorina set after the fall of the
empire and before the emergence of the
first time I love do they really they
really committed to trolling people all
right what's okay there's a pin comment
here if you are upset by this video
might I advise you to uh celebrate the
holiday wait half an hour watch it again
and let us know how your that Jer
I mean I enjoyed it but I'll do that and
yeah I love these top coffins jake smith
how many more lies have I been told by
the council Darth Vader Yoda pulls
middle finger
wait is this legal people are watching
the official trailer and Darth Vader
voice no well have you seen that thing
where it's like the Spanish track and it
sounds so much better
no I have - Darth Vader's know is way
better no idea I gotta say this this was
much needed for me today I quite enjoyed
this nice there's a rough weekend and
this really it's a really great way to
kick off this special holiday if you
guys are legally able to celebrate go
celebrate the social distancing in your
home if it is illegal for you to
celebrate do it anyway do it in private
the big deal
oh yeah yeah half-baked dang
if only I started celebrating before
Phil I mean I gotta say I don't need to
be quote-unquote celebrating right now
in order to enjoy this but maybe I'll
celebrate tonight and take Jeremy's
advice and re-watch this because yeah
this was good while watching pineapple
Express
yeah I sure did to that design jewel
screen yeah no this was a blasty blast
Thank You IgM for doing this dislikes
are so connecting neck right now this is
what it is at the time of cutting our
reaction up together that's why they're
so neck-and-neck I've seen K people just
harsh in the buzz uh I just take a joke
guys take a joke who cares so there's
more serious things in the world's going
on to get mad about this is not
something that would you rather add a
delay announcement yeah take the piss
out of yourself thing's already delayed
this was fun super fun Thank You IGN I
liked it I did yeah I subscribed a GN
subscribe to the real rejects if you
haven't done so already make sure to
click that notification bell to get
notified whenever we've got a youtube
video up check us out on patreon we just
finished my hero academia season 4
finale that's going up today there's a
whole bunch of other shows as well and
in the midst of this pandemic we are
also on Stardust a hell of a lot so many
other
platforms John has just got us started
on a discord so yeah go to or discord as
soon as you can and last but not least
Derek Mitchell and Victoria Huntley I
thought it'd be fun for this month to do
some fanfiction of our patronage X of
what would happen if they met each other
I wrote this one John you play Victoria
she's British and I'll play Derek
Mitchell friend from my I think it's
Kansas does tech he was a lyft driver
you'll see why I mentioned that right
now he's basically Superman interior
lift ride Derek Mitchell lyft driver
takes up Victoria Huntley a British
woman cosplaying as Hermione Granger
visiting San Diego comic-con so let's
just imagine Victoria humping in the
backseat well Derek Mitchell drives so
is this your first time going a
comic-con it is I traveled all the way
from the UK to be here oh wow this is
the furthest I've traveled I picked up
arrived from my home state which Greg
couldn't remember the state of at the
time of writing this which took me to
San Diego so I figured why not do some
rides while I'm here what do you do
I'm the look driver obviously you picked
me up right right I guess I get a little
flustered talking a pretty woman oh
thank you yeah I've always had a thing
for Hermione Granger I mean after she
started growing up in prisoner of
azkaban I stopped thinking she was hot
before that hell yeah that's kind of
creepy yeah I don't know what Greg
always writes me like I'm some creepy
lyft driver when technically I got a new
job working Tech and left the ride
service industry behind what about you
what do you do for a living well in the
UK yeah you single I'm kind of turned on
oh no wow
I'm actually engaged to a very
attractive gentleman who likes to ride
around in the tube and have a spot of
tea while watching the Queen on the
television because you know I'm British
sounds like Greg writes you like a
stereotype Tim yeah I'm not sure how he
thinks I'll have a successful writing
career if we can't retain more detailed
facts of when writing these showers well
why isn't your boyfriend here fiance oh
sorry why isn't your friend
benefits here he was watching Prince
Charles videos on the telly and forgot
to pack his luggage or as us Brits call
it luggage so I think we're not going
back to your hotel
expelliarmus Derek Mitchell vanishes
from the driver's seat killing both
Derek and Victoria in the process due to
a collision into a crowd of people
waiting in line for Hall H and that's
why comic-con was really cancelled in
2020 our patron objection never meet